all I'm offering is the truth nothing
more
hi friends and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes countdown let's face it Keanu
Reeves may be from Canada but he is he
is darn National Treasure here in
America I mean from Bill and Ted to The
Matrix to John Wick the guy's acting
career spans numerous decades many
franchises plus a whole bunch of box
office hits and critical acclaim
[Music]
number 10 Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure
movie that made Keanu Reeves the patron
saint of Woe this film features Keanu
and Alex Winter as the main characters
two dudes who are just trying to form a
band but end up in a time traveling
phone booth with George Carlin so that
they don't fail history class Alex and
Keanu not only reprise their roles in
the 1991 and 2020 sequel films but they
actually also provided voices for a Bill
and Ted animated series that first ran
on CBS in 1990 and all of that epic
franchising started with this one where
the critics consensus says that Reeves
and winter are just Charming Goofy and
silly enough to make this fluffy time
travel Adventure work dudes you guys are
gonna go back in time yeah you are going
to have the most excellent adventure
through history
who are you guys were you dude
no way
number nine John Wick
the movie about one of the most deadly
assassins and in arguably one of the
most stylish too according to me kicking
off what would become at least a four
film franchise this movie introduced
keanu's John Wick character a retired
and legendary assassin who sets out for
some serious Revenge after his really
cute puppy is killed and John Wick was
followed by not only multiple film
sequels each one more successful than
the last by the way but also video games
and comic books critics consensus calls
it a satisfying return to action for
Keanu Reeves and my consensus is that is
literally the cutest dog I've ever seen
on screen
stole that for me
for me killed that for me
people keep asking if I'm back and I
haven't really had an answer
but now yeah I'm thinking I'm back
number eight Rivers Edge
and what people often consider a
breakout role for Keanu Reeves this 1986
film follows a group of teenagers in
Northern California who are forced to
deal with their friend's murder of his
girlfriend now among the very strong
ensemble cast is Keanu Reeves's mat one
of the few kids in this film who
actually seems to have a conscience
speaking of which Veteran New York Times
critic Janet Maslin called the Young
cast in this movie natural and credible
while specifically calling out Keanu
Reeves as being affecting and
sympathetic which I think most of us
would agree on those two words
shouldn't have hit me
don't be stupid Tim
John
I'm your brother give me the gun
number seven The Matrix
the movie that really changed all our
lives I mean and what turned out to be a
cultural phenomenon at the turn of the
century Keanu Reeve stars in the film as
a computer hacker named Neo who uncovers
an evil cyber intelligence now what's
really interesting is that the
screenplay was reportedly sent to Sandra
Bullock at one point with the suggestion
of rewriting the lead as a female get
this Will Smith Nicholas Cage Brad Pitt
Val Kilmer and Leonardo DiCaprio all
turn down this role Paving the way for
Keanu to win the role over Johnny Depp I
mean can you say star power
foreign
[Music]
number six John Wick chapter 2.
now this sequel once again follows Keanu
Reeves as retired super assassin John
Wick but this time he is forced back
into his old life to fulfill an oath to
a crime Lord don't you just hate when
that happens Keanu is so committed that
he did three more months of training on
top of what he learned the first time
around in things like Jiu Jitsu driving
and Marksmanship
[Music]
yourself
so of course number five is going to
John Wick chapter three Parabellum I
mean this film checks in as the highest
grossing franchise installment on the
Tomato Meter so far and once again is
directed by Chad stachelski and starring
Keanu Reeves and it didn't take long for
chapter 3 to become the highest grossing
film in the franchise 10 days to be
exact on its way to earning over
326 million dollars worldwide I mean
that is good enough to green light a
fourth film very well my son
cast aside your weakness and reaffirm
your 30 to the table
Mr John Wick
Ed
number four always be my Maybe
and what is one of my favorite cameos of
all time this Netflix film stars Ali
Wong and Randall Park as Sasha and
Marcus two childhood friends who cross
paths 15 years after falling out and
then try and start a relationship
despite their very different lives
what's amazing about Keanu in this movie
is that he actually plays a version of
himself who is dating Sasha now director
Khan once considered the casting of
Keanu Reeves to be a pipe dream but it
turns out that Keanu is actually a huge
fan of Randall Park stand-up and said
that he was honored to be involved I
mean what a guy so where's your man
oh there he is
foreign
number three Much Ado About Nothing this
romantic comedy is based on William
Shakespeare's play of the same name and
it was actually adapted for the screen
and directed by Kenneth bronoff who also
stars in it now among the Stellar
Ensemble casts Keanu Reeves is Don John
the evil half-brother to Denzel
Washington's character and while he was
sharing the screen with actors like
Denzel and Kenneth and Kate Beckinsale
was big for Keanu he actually also said
that during filming he befriended actor
Brian blessed who taught him how to
meditate which I just really love
let me bid you welcome my Lord
being reconciled to the prince your
brother
I owe you all Duty oh thank you
I am not of many words
but I thank you
number two speed
Kiana's career was on The Fast Track by
1994 so it's very fitting that he
starred in this film as a cop trying to
stop a bomb from blowing up on a city
bus that can't go below 50 miles per
hour now first time director yonda Bond
who would direct twister a couple years
later brought in Joss Whedon a week
before filming began to rework keanu's
character to be more Earnest and it must
have worked because speed grossed over
350 million dollars and it won two
Oscars in sound categories and the
critics consensus calls it taut tense
and energetic with outstanding
performances from Keanu Reeves and his
co-stars
[Applause]
thank you
yeah
a little taller
and last but not least number one Toy
Story 4. now with three very certified
fresh installments already in the
franchise this one finds the usual group
of toys with the new owner and on a new
adventure Keanu Reeves joined an already
legendary voice cast as duke Kaboom a
Canadian Daredevil toy with a motorcycle
which was Act actually inspired by real
life stuntman Evil Knievel whose toy
commercials from the 1970s were very
similar to Dukes in the film it also
happened to win the Oscar for best
animated feature making this the first
franchise to win the award twice whoa
all thanks to Duke Kaboom I mean sure
why not
Rajon was so excited when he got me
after Christmas
it was the happiest Boxing Day of My
Life
[Applause]
come on
I was ready to finally do what I was
made to do
but when Rajon realized I couldn't jump
as far as the toy in the commercial
[Music]
why
well there you guys have it our list of
the man the myth and the legend that is
Keanu Reeves be sure to stay tuned to
Rotten Tomatoes for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am a major Keanu Reeves fan
and your host Naz Perez and we'll see
you back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you